في التاسع والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي
استعرضنا هنا في العربيه 360 كيف اعترضت
لاستخبارات الاوكرانيه مكالمات هاتفيه
لجنود رؤوس تحدث فيها عن ارتكابهم جرائم
حرب وعن مواقعهم وعن فشالهم في دخول
العاصمه كاف حينها تحدثنا كيف عصى الجنود
الرسل المنتشرون في الخنادق والحفر وفي
المنازل المحتله في المنطقه المحيطه
ببوتشا وهي ضاحيه غربيه من كيف عصوا
الاوامر من خلال اجراء مكالمات غير مصرح
بها من هواتفهم المحموله الى زوجاتهم
واصدقائهم وكانت ربما سببا انذاك في كشف
مواقعهم وفي فشله هجومهم ومخططهم قال احد
الجنود في تلك المكالمات المسربه ان ثلث
الفوج الذي يخدم في مبيد بينما افاد جنود
من الفوز
جوا بان الكتيبه الثانيه باكملها المكونه
من 600 جندي قد تم القضاء عليها الاخطاء
ذاتها تتكرر ولم يتعلم القدر رؤوس والجنود
لم يتعلموا اي درس من الماضي على ما يبدو
وهذا امر مستغرب من الجميع في الواقع
لنستذكر واياكم احدى هذه المكالمات
غير رئيس روسي قائد الحرب في اوكرانيا
ثلاث مرات منذ بدئها في فبراير من العام
الماضي
تغير الاشخاص لكن الاخطاء مستمره وتتكرر
وبطريقه مستهجنه يقول خبير امني امريكي
لصحيفه وسط جورنال ان العقليه السوفياتيه
لا تزال تحكم الجيش الروسي المركزي
المطلقه وتراجع مراكز القياده واضافه الى
بعدها عن مسرح العمليات بسبب الخوف من
الضربات الاوكرانيه كل ذلك اسهم بخلق
العديد العديد من المشكلات اللوجستيه اضف
الى ذلك تخزين الاسلحه الخاطئ كما ذكرنا
ضربه مكيف كالمحرجه قد تقود الى انتقام
روسي كبير وهو محذر منه الرئيس
شخصيا قائلا ان روسيا ست شنه هجوما كبيرا
خصوصا مع اطلاق جماعه قوميه غير معروفه
تدعم ارامل الجنود الروس دعوات لبوتن تطلب
منه اعلان تعبئه واسعه لملايين الروس
واغلاق الحدود لضمان تحقيق النصر في
اوكرانيا
هذا العام بمعالجه اكثر ما تحتاجه
اوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي قبل التعبئه
التي تعدها الدوله الارهابيه وهذا هو
بالضبط الوقت الذي يتعين علينا فيه مع
شركائنا تعزيز دفاعتنا ليس لدينا ادنى شك
في ان اسياد روسيه الحاليين سوف يرمون كل
ما تبقى لديهم لمحاوله قلب الوضع بالحرب
وعلى الاقل تاخير هزيمتهم